you have to show the Palestinians there
is another way jual Noah Harari said we
have to offer Palestinians who don't
support Terror who are not anti-semitic
we have to offer them a clear way how to
live freely and in a dignify weight in
their own Homeland this is the term used
by Harari I don't buy thiso leftist
version of what Israel is doing there is
simply
neocolonialism colonizing a country no
Jewish people have a certain right to
the land but not exclusive right but so
do Palestinians the only way to resolve
again the point is now from the site of
Israel to offer Palestinians a clear
hope not just to put pressure on them